uh on your side if you're a good fit for
that job
but
that been your experience
that has that has 100 percent been my
experience and i saw a question pass by
but i said maybe i'm having trouble with
the interface it said
um you know can you explain with an
example and the example is i mean i'll
tell you my my experience right i had
started thinking about i want to change
roles and when it also happened that
some recruiters were reaching out to me
so i
worked with the recruiter to literally
say okay what are the kinds of things
this recruiter is
recruiter recruiting for
and they walked me through you know they
were looking for storage domain
experience they were looking for
somebody who had led a team of a certain
size they were looking for here were the
gaps in their current leadership profile
that they wanted to fill so they got
very specific about you know they wanted
somebody who had done storage but also
had a lot of enterprise experience they
wanted somebody who had brought things
to market
not just as a 1-0 but as a tour and
through your version so i mean i'm
getting very specific here that may or
may not apply to all of you but
you so recruiters are looking for
certain things ask them what that is
yeah and you're you're with google cloud
platform specifically within within
google so
the
um
skill set and the experience that
they're looking for is going to be very
specific
as you said managing cloud storage and
experience of developing and bringing
products to market
um
now of course
most of our audience are not going to be
at the level where they're going to be
asked about
that depth of experience if you're a
refresher coming out there's not the
expectation that you have
you know all those years of experience
but what are some of the things that
people can do to prepare
in order to make themselves
stand out from
their peers
i think that's a great question stuart
especially for this audience
so i'll go out and say let's we're
talking mainly about the engineering
roles here happy to talk about other
roles at another time but for
engineering roles at more junior roles
you are
most companies are going to take you
through a set of coding interviews right
and you have to decide what tools you
want to use lead code is obviously a
very common one i'm not you know i'm not
saying you should or shouldn't do that
that's up to you but
find a way to get good at these coding
interviews that is very very important
um ultimately if you're looking for a
software engineering job your job is
going to be 60 70 coding in a junior
role uh and 20 30
of system design right so make sure you
really nail the lead code or or whatever
tool you decide to use um
again i i know everybody needs a
different amount of prep time but
i think it's very normal for people to
take you know a couple hours each day
for a good month or two so that's the
rigor of interview prep for just the
coding interviews that i would recommend
is you know really drill into and lead
code and other tools again i keep saying
lead code that's not my intention pick
whatever tools you want they really you
know formulate into algorithms and
various different styles of um areas of
coding so do a lot of that practice
whether you come from a technical or
non-technical background
coding is going to be a part of most
engineering role interviews right and
now you can split up right you could
have a lot of experience in the system
side or you may be a front-end developer
it's fine when you go into your
interview you can be very clear about
what technologies what language you like
and most companies will be very open to
picking you know if you're a javascript
person they're not going to try to get
you to code in java right so
be specific about what roles you're
interviewing for and really prep
the other things a couple other things
that have caught people by surprise some
companies if you're interviewing at the
five six plus level years of experience
some companies will throw at you a code
review interview
because they want to see yes you're
really solid at coding but are you also
doing that community work of reviewing
other people's code and
how how intentional and how
detail-oriented are you with that
again ask your recruiter if that could
be one of the interviews and if so prep
and and the best way i've found to prep
for that is to prep with a partner
somebody else you know who's
interviewing you know you become the
person who's writing the code let them
be your code reviewer switch roles do
that one-on-one prep i think that's
invaluable
the third area that's very common
maybe not right out of college but even
a few years after even at three or four
years after we start asking people for a
little bit of system design
now that system design level depends if
you're you know 15 years experience we
will ask you to do things like design
youtube for instance um if you're more
junior we may ask you to do much simpler
things like think about an event
monitoring system and just the
monitoring piece of it or just the
reporting piece of it we may break the
problem down into a smaller subset and
ask you to to do that
now for that also there are a ton of
resources available youtube and there's
a lot of actually tools um again i won't
name any specific one because i don't
want to
anchor you on that but if you google
around you find
there are lots of practice
sessions possible like there are
interview practice sessions but there's
also
um youtube videos that people will walk
through for instance if you've been
asked to design youtube what storage
database api what should you use do you
need a cdn do you need a load balancer
all all of that you know all of those
things are available in prep so i would
say
if you take anything away from this
it's prep you the more prepped you are
the more when you go into a situation
you handle you you practice a similar
question you will be more confident
there and i know sometimes that's
obvious
but sometimes we we tend to forget that
but i'm sorry i'm going along on this
i'm going to add one more thing here
sure
a lot of times we all get very focused
on prepping for this system design thing
from the functional pieces right
make sure you're thinking about
non-functional requirements as well
so how do we break that out um i'll go
back to my design youtube example for
functional requirements when you're
designing youtube you're going to think
about how do i upload videos how do i
subscribe how do i follow what database
i need etc the non-functional
requirements are equally important
what's the usability like what's the
reliability what's the scale how many
users hence you know what is my size of
everything that i need so i would say
make sure you're thinking about that
equally important
in your interview take the time really
take the time
to uh for the interviewer take the first
three or five five minutes to
validate your understanding so for
instance it's to what was my interview
i'd say hey stewart here's what i'm
thinking you know tell me more about
what scale stuart says let's assume ten
thousand users okay great ten thousand
so what how many videos do we think
we'll be uploading per minute right
or you make an assumption and validate
with the interviewer that that data
assumption is correct
this is a really good way to build a
rapport with the interviewer but also
get really crisp about what are the
non-functional requirements of this
system very very important don't forget
to do it
yeah i mean one of the things that
um
at least personally i i experienced when
i was a student
was i would
study to
make instant responses to
questions it's like a pavlovian ring of
the bell and
you do this thing
so
you would
look at a problem and say oh i
understand what the what the what
they're asking here and here's the
response that's not the case
in interviewing is it i mean it's really
more
you're not just
doing a
instant response to a prompt
you're really in a process of
conversation or communication
where you need to show that
you're
both as you said listening as well as
thinking about the solution to
whatever question is is being put
before you so
um what are your thoughts on
on that kind of interactive part of the
of the process
you you said it very well stuart all
through the process an interviewer
even when they've asked you a system
design question
they are also getting signals on are you
listening
are you asking questions are you just
rushing to solve a problem or are you
going to be the kind of collaborative
engineer on the team who will ask their
peers for input who will be active
listening not just listening and nodding
their head but actually just doing their
own thing but going you know having a
conversation and really thinking about
the design before jumping into a
solution so
100 and you know you you think you're
only doing system design but you are
actually being interviewed on how you're
approaching the problem as much as the
actual uh design
right
um
that brings up an interesting aspect of
interview questions and and it's
one of
uh in the past it's been one of the kind
of favorite questions i've liked to ask
people but
it's also one that you you know you're
going to get which is
uh tell us about a time
this is the question where
tell us about a time you solved this
type of problem tell us about a time you
encountered this situation
um
this is
an opportunity for the the interviewee
to tell a story but how would how
do people learn or prep
have those stories ready at hand and
tell them well
i love this point stuart because
early in my
in career and you know my first
time some change jobs i would just go in
and tell these stories right but i
realized very quickly that i was telling
the same one or two stories to all the
interviewers
and
because you know those were my best
favorite projects i had solved uh worked
on etc right
and especially and you know maybe 10 15
years ago that was okay in today's day
and age
your interviewers are taking notes very
actively they are being shared across
the panel and at the end of the day when
the decision makers review your
interview notes if they see that you
told the same story about this amazing
problem you solved in five different
ways they're going to say well you just
solved one big problem right
so what exactly to your point
sometimes we get so busy preparing for
the coding interviews and the system
design interviews that we forget to prep
for these more soft skills right so i
would say again if you already know
which companies you're interviewing for
go look up their interview process some
companies have very clear you know they
have role related questions leadership
questions etc and they're very very
organized
but even if you don't know that and if
you're just generally preparing
think about most companies will want
answers about leadership about how
you've influenced peers
how you've managed conflict
how maybe there was unpopular you had an
opinion that was not the closing one but
did you stand up for your beliefs
conversely when did you get some
feedback and you changed your mind and
how did that go
when you had to make some tough calls
about maybe you had a feature but you
had to ship it quickly and your manager
was pressuring you and you had to make a
shortcut what did you do how do you
handle it
all of this i'm sharing is not rocket
science it's all available if you google
it for interview prep
but for
think about five or six or seven of
these high level topics and prepare a
story or an example for each ideally
something that is distinct
from each other not the same story but
you know and what you will find is once
you start preparing these stories a
leadership story can often also be used
for a managing ambiguity uh question
right so the question doesn't have to be
exact but come up with five or six
really solid scenarios in your college
like maybe these could be college
projects or in your current job
and have them ready and this will go
this will go a long way
one other tip i'd add is if you can
prepare two stories for each of these uh
interviewers these days know that you
know candidates are preparing for a
leadership question right so they'll ask
you one and sometimes they'll say
give me another example they're trying
to see if you can think on your feet so
i would say go get ahead of them you
know really prepare prepare um for for
for these stories but with themes and
that will go a long way
to talk about soft skills one of the
other aspects of soft skills is
how how the individual comes across in
the interview in terms of
confidence presentation
thing
and
how
how do you recommend that people prepare
for a situation like in a job interview
at a prestigious company where
you may feel pressure they may feel
nervousness they may
introverted people who
aren't
that used to talking to other people
they may be extroverts who talk too much
um
how what are the kinds of things that
people can do to prepare
for the the
human interaction level of the
uh aside from technical
100 100
mock interviews are my best best
recommendation you can do them with a
friend
with a spouse
a buddy a colleague or get online there
are tons of
i mean
there are paid services but actually
there are a
port load of free services available as
well and the idea is they're just
pairing people up right like wait okay
so so it's free for you it's free for me
because we're helping each other
make use of those
really double down on that i mean
there's a bunch of channels on discord
again i don't want to you know say one
company over the other but there's a lot
of places where you can go find this
just just google it um do the interviews
do the prep have your stories ready say
them out aloud to someone that someone
will give you feedback that is really
the best way to figure out how your
personal interaction is going
um
in this context um stuart if you don't
mind i saw a question that i think is
relevant which was
what is your weakness uh somebody monica
asked this question online and the chat
i think by the way that's a really good
one
i'll tell you a pet peeve of mine is
when somebody says
tell me about a weakness and they
actually take something which is
actually a strength and they say you
know i'm a perfectionist you know so i
end up just digging deep in and you know
i'm often saying being a perfectionist
is okay maybe if you're too
you know detailed like it could be a
weakness but it actually sometimes is a
strength so i would say don't fake it
come up with a genuine weakness
area of growth
and be open that you're working on it
right one of the examples like again i i
don't want to tell you one answer or two
answers but think about what you
genuinely struggle with and position it
as something i'm aware of this i'm
acutely aware and i'm trying to get
better at it one thing could be
that
sometimes i chime in too much because i
get excited and i'm you know very much
in the conversation and sometimes i tend
to speak up a lot and i'm trying very
hard to tone that down and you know be
careful about how i speak up
another could be the opposite of that
which is i'm not a very confident person
i'm an introvert and so even though i
think i have good ideas when i'm in a
large group i don't speak up enough
so i would again i'm giving you two
completely opposite ends of the example
to show you that both of these if
genuinely explained to an interviewer
can be good examples of this is a
weakness and i am working on it i'm
aware of it
yeah
yeah one of the questions i i used to
ask people uh
in interviews was
can you tell me about
a time when you
have to admit that you failed where
where everything
was
it was
somewhere under your control it wasn't a
circumstance that that
bit you
but you have to admit that you messed up
somehow and asking people that question
um
gets them to reveal a little bit about
themselves
have you used that type of technique as
well
always that is uh i have
asked that question and i have been i
have been asked that question in almost
every interview steward so thank you for
bringing it up again what the
interviewers are trying to figure out is
how you handle failure like every one of
us has made mistakes and has done
something less
in a less ideal way or in a way that now
you know after the after the fact we
would know how to do better
it takes a lot to admit it but the
biggest thing they're looking for is how
you handle it and how you acknowledge
that you are better for it so stuart
thanks for bringing this up favorite
question to ask and also have been
asking every interviewer make sure you
have one or two examples of this
prepared and really talk through about
how you are better today because of that
learning
yeah i think that last part is very
important because you don't want to
leave people with the impression that oh
well
i made the mistake but you know that's
life
exactly you know one of the other things
people have done if they are not prepped
for it especially is they will try to
talk about that mistake as you know it
was somebody else's problem or they
they'll try to because we get defensive
if we are not prepared sometimes we get
defensive and we and we're in an
interview right we want to show the best
version of ourselves and now we're
talking about a failure so we try to
you know make it sound like it was
somebody else's fault never ever ever do
that like that is the worst sign in an
interview because an interviewer is
getting the sense that yeah you're not
going to own up to your failure so be
very
inward focused talk about what you could
have done better certainly talk about
how you could have influenced other
people as well to do better but make it
more inward focused
yeah
that's excellent advice
um so
on the flip side
you know as as i'm
said it's a
process of communication
and
interviewees go into the process
understanding that they're going to be
asked questions
going to reveal information about their
background
skills interests capabilities
but
what about the other direction what are
the questions that people should
ask interviews what what are the
interviewers i should say
what are the questions that are
important to ask and what are areas to
avoid
great question stewart
another one of my pet peeves is
when
most interviewer interviews i will leave
the last five minutes or eight minutes
to say hey what questions do you have
and when people
ask me very frivolous questions or it's
clear they haven't thought about it that
is a pet peeve of mine also because that
shows that
it gives me the impression that you know
i caught you flat-footed that you just
cared about just getting the job you
actually aren't you know you're just
interviewing for your next pay raise or
the next job you don't actually care and
most times people want to know that you
care right so
so
the
a good opportunity here when when i say
to you as an interviewer hey tell me
what questions you have a really good
opportunity is to show that you have
done a lot of research about the company
about the role and really that is also
by the way part of your interview right
you're coming across as someone who
preps so ask about the team ask about
the role ask about what makes a
successful engineer ask you know if
they're a person who's on the team if
they if they're going to be a peer ask
them you know when they joined what are
the things that surprised them the most
ask you know if they have been at the
company a long time ask them
what has changed like what was it like x
years ago
how has to have things changed do a
little bit of research on your
interviewer hopefully you know who the
interviewer is going to be in advance
look them up on linkedin do a bit of
research on them ask them you know how
they got interested in this area
make it clear that you are interested um
not just
you know that you were doing this just
just because you know somebody some
recruiter called you right so very
important create a question bank
um you can have a generic question back
but my advice is create a question back
for each company that you are
interviewing at then you can have very
specific questions about you know the
business or the technology the
technology stack what is you know how
how are they handling tech debt you know
how do they pay down tech tech versus
doing features ask all these questions
what not to ask
don't ask about pay
i would recommend stay away from
questions about
i think you can ask questions about what
times people usually come in or not but
i would leave that for later like if the
first thing you're asking is what time
do people come in what time do they
leave
you can ask it but i generally tend to
avoid that i tend to focus more on the
role and the culture and the company and
you know what what makes it successful
uh but you could ask right you you could
ask what are the biggest gaps on the
team that need to be filled right just
stay away from the more negative side of
things pay or um you know what up what
are who are the kinds of people on this
team don't make it
personal in that sense
yeah
generally speaking don't ask about what
the
rumors or or bad publicity has happened
that you've seen in the press about the
company that
not necessarily something that they want
to talk about at that point
what what are some of the questions that
you've seen um
interviewees
mess up in their interviews
great really great point
i'm going to jump in and take another
question here from the because it's
relevant also
and that question was if i don't know
the answer to a question how to say this
in a professional way and ask the
interviewer to either move on to that
question or ask later in the interview i
had this experience by the way
uh during my google interviews where i i
was asked a question which i really
wasn't prepared for
and i said again you have to be
authentic self you have to be genuine
you can just say hey that question i'm
not you know really being able to think
of a good response for that can we come
back to that later or maybe can we skip
that for now
the interview was interview was
perfectly professional about it they
said absolutely no problem most
interviewers have a big question bank
right they're not going to take it
personally they have seven questions
they were going to ask you five anyway
most time unless that was a very
specific question that was about that
job
um
most interviewers will be fine with it
and you know i'm here i'm at google i i
didn't get fired i mean i didn't get not
accepted for that one answer so just um
be very authentic about it and you know
very professionally just move on and it
should be
90 of the time it should be just fine
um
so that's a good way of handling it
versus if you if you're nervous and you
just
the worst thing you can do is you know
you don't know a good answer to the
question and you just fumble your way
through and fake it that is the absolute
worst way to handle that so don't mess
up in that way right the other thing
i've seen people mess up is
it's really simple
but the elevator pitch you know the
first question if i ask you is hey
stuart tell me about yourself tell me
why you're interested in the role and
you kind of fumble through that like no
no you should always have your 30
seconds to one minute about who you are
what you do why you're a good fit there
is no excuse to not prep for that don't
don't fumble that up right make a good
first impression
other question i have seen people fumble
which is really again disappointing is
you know people say hey why are you
interested in this role or why this
company
and people give a genetic answer you
know oh you know google is such a great
company no that's that's that means you
didn't do your research
dig in
why right give me one or two good
reasons why i should continue this
conversation
another very important question is um
you know we've gone through a few set of
questions maybe and then i say stuart
hey tell me if i asked this particular
product management peer what would they
say about you and people get worried
about that because they're thinking
about should i give you
everything awesome or should i you know
how should i answer that and i would say
prep for that question
and prep for what this person would say
genuinely about
you know one or two positives about you
and maybe one thing they would generally
say you know here's something they could
improve on so
prep really prep about what would
personnel say about you especially if
you are making reference to you know i
work closely with these engineers or the
product managers to go solve this
prep for what will those people say
about you
last thing i'll say about messing up or
can be handled better is
when people
get the balance between i and we wrong
right there are times where you really
want to talk about how did i solve this
problem
but there's also a good time to say we
as a team
right if you keep going i i then the
major question in the interviewer's head
is well how do you work with the team
and if your entire interview is about we
you know we did this we did that with
that with that then my question is going
to be well what particular thing did you
solve
so
in your interview be cautious about this
and find a way in your interview to find
a good balance between the i and the we
yeah and
that's so important i mean you talk
about
an accomplishment that the team had you
still have to talk about
why were you an important member of that
team and what did you contribute
to that team effort um
so
as you said the balance is so important
yeah even if you're a new even if you're
just coming out of college right when
you're going to give the example for
project you did it's very likely you did
it with someone else find that balance
between you know as my
code partner and i were working through
this here's some things we did you know
i took on this role they took on that
role you know make make sure you're
because any any company you work at
you're going to be working with a team
even if you come in as an l3 new hire
you are going to be working on a team so
make sure even if you're talking about a
project you did talk about the i and the
way in
that yeah
um so
thinking about both your role as an
interviewer of
cancer candidates and an interviewee who
has gone through this process
what are some of the questions
coming from the other side of the table
that have
uh flummoxed you that have thrown you
for a loop
great great one i mean like i told you
one was a very specific design question
that i was asked and i had not run into
that particular scenario before um i i
just wasn't familiar with with those
semantics and i i stated that
uh another thing was this is a really
good question that i now prep for is
somebody asked me teach me something
that you recently learned
technology-wise
right
and i had been learning some you know i
had been
doing some new technology actually that
this was long ago i was doing some react
native work and i had been from a react
background
and um i talked about it but i i didn't
do a great job of explaining right and
what this person was trying to get from
that interview was you learn something
and it could be something small like you
you discovered some algorithmic change
that you should make to your code
explain to somebody how or why
right um so i think that's a great
question and i i use it all the time now
which is to see how would a person
explain something to somebody else uh
because that just shows how well you
understand it
yeah i mean that was one of the things
when i was studying martial arts is that
you know
the
expression was you don't know it until
you can teach it
very well um
but the other thing that that comes out
of that question
is
if we're going to rely on you for a
particular
[Music]
capability or skill
how will you help the team
come along with you
on that so
that's a that's a really important
question
um and any other ones that you can think
of that have
really
allows you to stop and
you think
yeah i mean i i actually used some of
these examples in the previous ones the
the first time somebody asked me what
would this person say about you
you know i
it was a very instant reaction of
if you say only good things about
yourself that's not true but if you say
only areas of improvement that's not
good either so finding that right
balance the first time somebody asked me
that question i really had to think
about it uh very carefully and i don't
think i did a good job answering it so
since then i i now prepped that
prep for that
yeah and
it
let me think of like if i can remember
the point i was just about to make but
if if not i'll just move on um
there's a bunch of audience questions uh
yeah we can we probably
we probably should be getting to the q a
at this point because
i can start i can start picking some of
them there were a couple questions in
here about
salary expectations um
you know i i will stay away from this
one and i'll tell you why i think this
is very country specific as well in the
us we are not allowed to ask people for
salary expectations
with that said
a lot of times people say well give me a
range uh there are tools like levels.fyi
that actually give you salary ranges for
different companies
uh and different jobs so i don't have a
great answer for this i would say
the best way to do it this is what i've
always done he said i'm not going to
give you a range i would like you tell
me
what is your range for this job
i would rather know from you and then
you know we can talk about if that's the
range i'm looking for not so as much as
possible i would try to and sometimes
the recruiters will not tell you this in
an email get on the phone with them and
say can you give me an approximate range
so that we can you know agree on whether
i should even continue interviewing
um yeah
um
like you said like you said it's a very
tricky point because you you don't want
to pin the interviewer down
or but you do want to make sure that
there's an overlap between
your expectation and what is on offer so
exactly exactly uh another question is
how do tech companies or companies in
general example in the us take breaks or
gaps in work after college for entrance
exam preps trying to change field health
problems you know the world has really
changed in the last 20 years i think
years ago this used to be a problem now
i think as long as you have a very
credible why
it is not a problem at all like it is
you know even as much as i was taking
care of um
you know an elderly parent or i just
needed a break because i was so tired or
as long as you convey that you are now
ready to come back and you're full all
in and you you know you're excited about
a role
i i have not worried about people taking
breaks i have not seen that as an issue
as it used to be you know years ago
okay
um
yeah
i do want to mention something that
that uh
for our
folks watching on the streaming services
we have a
typeform link and i will try to find it
and put it into the
uh
bring it out but you should have a
link that's been mentioned to you in the
comments
um and if you would follow that
folks uh to answer some questions about
your level of interest we'll get to that
in a little bit but i just wanted to
mention that before i forget um
but i do have a question that came in
here
abazar so he's talking about he asked a
question
how do you know the specific skill sets
that the company need
and
that comes down to how do you research
that
yeah i again
if you already have an interview lined
up
i would use your recruiter
if you don't
i would
look every company actually big
companies mostly right
have various things they're doing my
companies like google amazon meta
they have
jobs for application developers
front-end developers back-end
pure infrastructure people devops sre ml
like it's a broad broad field i mean
software engineering is a good place to
be right now because you could be doing
so many different things and you know
there's questions here about like
languages as well or which quote which
programming language
you know there is not one good answer
because
literally if you can code well in
languages there are plenty jobs for you
so i i'm not i'm not just running away
from this question i'm telling you that
there are so it really depends on your
interest where you want to go uh
companies like salesforce are very very
java based um google has like our teams
are doing a lot of c plus plus but
there's so many other roles that are
javascript there's c
um there's you know you can go dig deep
into analytics you can be a tensorflow
person like really i'm sorry i'm being
very broad here there is no one good
answer for this this question
and i would say um if you are interested
in a specific company then go research
their website go research their jobs
open most open jobs will tell you what
they are looking for so right it
requires research
okay
we can answer a related question just
prep have to get structured courses ask
this question does prep have to be
structured courses that portals like
simply learn offer or does one simply go
through quick labs for gcp etc
the answer is both
um i mean simply learn has some amazing
courses absolutely again back to the
question of what language you're trying
to learn what field you're trying to dig
into simply learn has a bunch of courses
quick labs is definitely a really good
way to go for gcp because you get
hands-on experience nothing like that so
unfortunately the answer is both yeah
um
we have some related questions about
the topic of people who are
uh at the higher end of the experience
scale so
i'm going to start with kaneshka's
question which is can someone be
overqualified for a role
you can be you can definitely be
overqualified for a role um because you
know you they may be looking for
somebody
with
you know
and it's not even how many years of
experience a lot of times people
focus on the years of experience i would
say not that it's the levels of a
company they're looking for someone l3
l4 who will come in junior level you may
already be at the point where you're
operating as a lead and you don't want
that role so yes you can be and i think
the best situation there would be to
work with the recruiter and say
sure for this particular role i'm over
qualified are there other
l5 roles in other parts of the
organization that i could apply for uh
don't take a role that you're
overqualified for that means that you
will end up stagnating for a couple
years before more senior opportunities
open up so my advice would be
unless it's your dream company and
you're like it doesn't matter just
that's fine otherwise i would say really
take a few more months and you will find
that right role
there we go um
so we have uh
ranganath and minaj both asking
questions about people who have around
20 years of experience or more
um and
at that level is it
about managerial capability or
more than tech skills
no it's um
no it's about both um of course it also
depends on what role you're interviewing
for but
you know i would say that
a lot of times it's actually your tech
capability of course it's your ability
to influence and manage and lead but it
is equally
do you know this domain and can you make
can you make vision
a reality right that there's two things
you're looking for with somebody with 18
20 years experience one is
can you be the person we bring in and
say what will this thing look like three
to five years from now you are setting
that vision
that is not a people vision that is
actually your technical vision and that
vision may include you know hey we're
going to have to acquire this this
technology because we don't have it and
our competitors are ahead it may be that
we need to start building now because
this is a long lead item that you know
is a platform plus software thing so it
is one one part of it is how do you set
that vision and another part you know
with that much experience we're looking
for people to say
you know you have this vision here's
what you have today how do we make this
a reality right because you have the
battle scars
you have been there done that and when
somebody shows your schedule and says
we're going to get this done in three
months you can say hey i've done this
before it's not three it's really six so
we're looking for senior people with the
battle scars really come in and say help
help guide that execution path to make
it a more predictable execution path
um
so
what
oh
i don't want to ask that question
because i think you've answered that one
um
can you tell
vivec a little bit more about
what the difference is when you get to
the level of an architect level
interview what are some of the
differences between that and a developer
role
yeah i mean it's it's it's
the scope
of influence right like a developer is
usually solving a certain problem like
for instance
this throttling algorithm i need to make
it more efficient i'm just throwing out
an example here right versus an
architect is solving and that you know
throttling algorithm
technology good good good good
engineering there could be an l4 l5
person
architect level is thinking about
how is this going to fit in the bigger
picture how is this
do we need to do throttling or do we
need to architect this whole system
because even with the throttling we put
in really this is not going to scale to
the level that we needed to three years
from now right so
um architects are usually influencing
things
two to five years from now they're
influencing teams of 100 plus people
so the decisions they make are going to
be then implemented by large teams of
people and they themselves then may dig
into very one
vertical part of that right they'll have
the broad influence and then they are
going deep into one small thing while
other people around them are being
directed to go implement the rest so
it's a scope
thing
um
blacksmith asked a good question about a
very common
interview question
uh how do you handle the very simple
question why are you the choice for this
job
great point and actually that should be
part of the elevator pitch if if you can
which is and this question can be either
up front or
right at the end of the interview if
it's right in the beginning if it's one
of the first questions you're asked
where you really haven't gone through
the back and forth with the interviewer
then you're just doing your elevator
pitch which is you know
you
are good with the technology
you have
a passion for the area like you have
deep interest in the area and you're
excited about this company because you
think it's a good future it can be a
generic answer if it's at the end of
your interview then try to pick up some
of the pieces threads from the
interviewer so maybe in your interview
there was questions about leadership
maybe there were questions about
resolving ambiguity maybe there were
questions about you know hey we have the
schedule we're not going to meet the
schedule how would you
pick the things that were the common
themes your interviewer is asking you
questions
that they are generally worrying about
on the team and are looking to improve
right pick themes from there and try to
bundle it up and say you know you asked
about x and y
i've already done x or y or i am very
passionate about it i really you know
i'm a solid you know i've been a mentor
you said you have a number of new
engineers on the team i've done this
before
how do you bring to the table what the
interviewer was concerned about in the
first three or five or uh six questions
they asked you
okay
take a quick look here
momentarily
so we had some questions
about people who are interested in the
area of product management and product
ownership are there
particular things that they should look
for to be asked in interviews
yeah i mean
product management is a job by itself
right in that case if you're interested
in product management you should be
applying for product management jobs by
the way i think engineers make fantastic
product managers so it's a really good
up you know thing to pursue most of my
all i would say are my favorite product
managers are have been engineers in
their past life so that you know that's
good
um
the product owner is an interesting role
that in different companies is played by
different people so i think this is
really very company specific and you
should dig in
uh at google and salesforce both our
product owners were product managers so
we didn't have engineers play that role
but
a lot of times in infrastructure jobs at
a lot of companies
you may not have the official title of
product owner but an engineer oftentimes
will sort of pseudo play that role
because you know an infrastructure
product is not necessarily being used by
the end customer it's being used by
internal customers so it could be
engineers on this team talking to
engineers on the upstream teams and and
they become the pseudo product owner so
i think this is very very company
dependent
um
in general i would make sure as you're
talking with your hiring manager the
recruiter may or may not know this but
the hiring managers will have a good
sense for you know will this role
include some part of a
you know a tech product owner you should
ask that question
um we have a couple of questions from
the linkedin audience one is from psy
who asks
um how do you say i don't know an
interview
in the best way
i think we talked about this earlier so
i i won't go into depth but it literally
is
i'm sorry i'm not familiar with this
would it be okay to move to a different
question i i mean you just be authentic
don't be super apologetic just say hey
this is not um
you know it's not something i've worked
on before i'm not something i've run
into
uh and do you really want to add if you
think that this is a key part of the job
you could ask is this a key part of the
job is this something i would have the
opportunity to learn while i'm in the
job so if you feel like that's the tone
of the question ask the question am i
expected to know this or is this
something i could learn
great
um priya asks uh a question i can't
quite get the clarification from her but
what she asked it is um
if you're going to be asked
what's the first 90 days after joining
the company going to look like for you
um
what do you respond
is there is there a way to respond to
that and is there a way to respond to
that if the interviewee asks you
what will my first 90 days look like
um
it's an interesting question usually
it's the other way around right the
interviewer
answers the question about you know i if
i'm interviewing for a job i want to ask
you my 2d manager
uh what will it look like but if
somebody asked me what would be my focus
i would say my
me i would say my focus would be on
listening learning learning
right really figuring out
what are the strengths weaknesses what
do i bring how can i add value
absorbing
more than speaking that that would be my
answer and and really framing a
point of view on
how can i add value to this team and
discuss that with my manager at regular
intervals that's what i would say but
that is not a question i've usually seen
being asked of the interviewee
um
omkar asks a question that's important
for
our audience in india which is
what about communication skills for
people who are fluent
in a native dialect rather than
in english
so that's a great question i would
upfront with the recruiter and your
interviewers say hey this is not my
native tongue i'm going to do my best
but please bear with me you know some
words are not natural to me right i i
would i would just again don't be
apologetic just matter of fact in a very
polite way state that then your
interviewers automatically are put in
that place where okay they're going to
give you a little more room
and you know your code will speak for
yourself or the system design will speak
for itself just
i would state that and sort of own that
don't be apologetic about it own it
and then we have a question from minaj
that reminds me of periods where
there was such a frenzy to hire people
that
people would be coming from
you know liberal arts backgrounds and
and being hired as as developers to be
trained after they they got hired but
nowadays it's not quite like that but
mennonite's question is
what technologies and subjects would a
non-computer science student
what should they study if they want to
pivot into
um
a tech company
yeah this is again
this is there is no one good answer for
this right you have to figure out what
interests you and so i'll go broad on
this
uh
there will always be jobs writing cc
plus plus code java code always
there will always be front-end jobs and
while the front-end platform may change
you know javascript is a good one these
days
um there will you know right now there's
a lot of jobs that are sort of low code
um there's a lot of jobs somebody else
has had asked about in rpa
uh the the the
rpa world
so
i
i'm not trying to evade the question i
think there is so much opportunity in
the software world that you have to
there is not going to be one right
answer that anybody can give you you're
going to have to kind of explore
what is the interest area you have that
you want to dig deep in that you know
you could be a solid python developer
and there's a ton of jobs there right
the interesting aspect
that
don't necessarily have to have
a deep technical background in order to
be successful in a technical company if
you have
other skills that can be brought to
other aspects of the of the organization
that's outside the scope of our webinar
today because we're talking about
developers and
engineers
but there are
many non-engineering roles
my background
i found that training as an engineer and
then going through marketing um i
learned that my passion is writing so
people who have the ability to do
written communications
who may not be
technically oriented
if they can pick up the understanding of
the of the domain they're working in
um
that's another
entirely different but
very interesting career path so
there's a lot of ways into an
organization
into a
tax firm one of the the the fang or as
they say man companies
um
so
we've reached the end of our hour and
i'd like to
apologize to the folks whose questions
we couldn't get to but i'm going to go
ahead
move on
so
i've got a couple of final things to
share with you
say goodbye
here
done the questions and answers so i want
to mention a program that simply learn
has that we've introduced
recently
this is a program for people who want to
get into full stack java development
this is a
program that features a 100 job
guarantee now it's only available in
india at present
you have to have
the
permits
approval to work in india
but
what we've done is partnered with a
number of different companies who have
agreed that they can take on
pretty much as many people as we can
graduate from these programs so
it's a six month program it's about 10
hours of
work a week
weekend classes every week and then
homework in between it's a comprehensive
program
that gives you uh some
hands-on experience with different tools
and platforms
as a full stack developer
based on online virtual instruction
so that you have a natural classroom
environment where you're interacting
with your instructors and peers
and
the
interesting feature of the program is
that we guarantee that within six months
of completing the program
after you've completed the six month
program another six months
we will help you find a job
you don't get a written job offer from
one of our partner companies we will
refund the program feed
goes through
java based stack
data structures back end
front end
and up to a capstone project so this is
uh the capstone project ties together
all the skills you learn in the program
you do a full stack development project
that you can then show off as
experience with the technologies and you
have
testing and as an elective
and i'll mention again the job guarantee
with regard to what we're talking about
today in terms of interviews
part of this
process is you get help with your resume
you get help with interview prep
practice interviews coaching
the job board access that gives you
access to the jobs listed by our partner
companies
and again if you don't get that written
job offer within six months you do get a
full refund of the program fees so
um
we're actually
very proud that we can we can do this
and very proud of the way we've
structured it it's not us gambling that
you're going to find a job
it's us
guaranteeing
that
one of our partner companies will be
able to take you on so
with that said i'm going to ask a quick
question before we move on which is
um
based on what i've just said is this
something that would interest you
are you interested in enrolling in this
program
and if so when
i'll leave this open for just a few more
seconds
i'm presuming it's going to be more
interesting to people who are
still in school pressures looking for
that first position
as opposed to people who are
far along in the career
don't need to necessarily have this type
of program to
help them move forward but
share the result of the poll
a pretty even distribution um
people saying yes about a third saying
maybe in a quarter saying
not interested but um
some of you want to do this right away
some of you are thinking about doing
something like this later on
um
so
you can find out more by
looking at our program page
and by contacting us at ask us
simplylearn.net
so i will put those links into the chat
for you
with that i'm going to thank
avital very very much for
being so generous with her time today
and her knowledge
um i
really appreciate that and behalf of the
audience i thank her
um
her
linkedin profile is up there on the
screen avatar aurora
i've got this
oh hold on a second
here we go
chat
here is the link to our program page by
the way
and
the email address to contact us for
questions about the programs talked
about
and you can learn more about other
programs
certainly at our website
in rpa
product management all the other areas
that came up in our questions today
i would invite
you if you're interested in data science
go ahead
and
join us for a
webinar data science that's coming up
next week
tuesday
uh
ronald van loon who is an expert uh
in the field we'll be talking about
how data science is being used to solve
some of the world's biggest business
challenges at present
i also want to mention that we will have
an upcoming
interview prep for data science
with
a
manager in the field
similar to this session but oriented
towards data science so keep an eye out
for that
i'll include that in the follow-up email
um just you can
keep track
if you're interested in that field but
with that
i'm going to go ahead and thank
everybody in the audience for being here
today
um
really appreciate you joining us we
invite you to follow us
on our social media channels at simply
learn
on facebook and twitter
simply learn on linkedin
and we hope we can welcome you into the
simply learn learning community so thank
you so much
and i do want to remind folks again
about the
type form
link
if you've been watching on one of our
streaming services you can use that so
again
that concludes our webinar for today
you